Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burns time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you instead of this shit.
I just got back from,
uh,
where the hell was I?
Phoenix,
Arizona.
Home with his son's home of the coyotes home with a fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
Grapefruit League net.
Grapefruit League.
What am instructional league?
I don't,
what the fuck is home of the Diamondbacks home with a fucking cocktails.
Okay.
Right.
I just got back from there.
Okay.
I'm coming home.
I'm taking a cab because I'm old.
I don't do fucking Uber.
I don't do Lyft.
I don't do any of that bullshit.
All right.
Fucking calling somebody and they just pull up in their car.
I just,
I'm on.
I don't,
I don't do it right if fucking take caps.
So pull up to my house and this is fucking
okay.
Whatever state truck there for.
These fucking guys are in my yard.
The gates open and one of the guys got a ladder up to the side of my house.
Okay.
So I just walk in.
I'm like,
ah.
Yeah.
Hey,
what are you guys doing?
And he goes,
Oh God,
some finally somebody is home.
Yeah.
I'm like,
what do you mean my wife didn't let you in?
He was like,
no,
there was no answer.
And I'm like,
then what are you doing here?
He goes,
well,
you know,
I keep coming by.
There's nobody here.
I got to check the meter.
You know?
They said,
you put a new electrical box.
You know,
you guys didn't have a home.
I mean,
what was I supposed to do?
I was like,
I dunno not coming to my fucking yard.
What did he,
what was I supposed to do?
Every time I go to the bank,
the bank's closed.
I mean,
what was I supposed to do?
Come back when they're fucking,
they're yet can't.
He just kept saying,
what was I supposed to do?
You're trespassing.
You asshole
fucking.
He just kept saying what and be,
you know something.
I actually kept my cooler.
I just calmly said,
I dunno not coming to my yard.
I go off my,
if I keep going over my neighbor's house and he's not there,
that doesn't mean give me a right to go in there.
And he goes,
well,
I got to go over.
I've got to get to the pole.
I mean,
you know,
when they changed the box,
the only put temporary whatever,
fucking things on there.
I got to put the right things on there.
I don't have your phone number.
I'm like,
well,
whose fault is that?
Some I fault.
Nobody asked me if you guys never called me,
or I guess you couldn't call me,
but you should have got from the,
from the electrician.
He goes,
yeah,
the electrician did give it to me.
Like,
oh,
there you go.
So the guy,
the guy is grabbing the ladder,
he takes it down and he's fucking walking out and go,
you know what do you,
what do you need to do here?
He goes,
no,
no.
You know,
go get out here.
It's just like,
dude,
you don't gotta fucking pout now.
You know what I'm saying is right
fucking walking.
You just open the gate.
You just fucking walk in.
Unbelievable.
I liked the guy.
The other guy immediately was fucking,
you know,
he's looking down.
He knew he was feeling lose.
The guy was wrong.
Okay.
The guy was basically like,
this is like the third time I come over here,
nobody ever answers the door.
I'm getting sick of this and he just fucking,
I don't know,
climbed over the wall.
I don't know what the gate's locked.
I don't know how they did it.
Me had a ladder.
I guess you just fucking went right up and over it.
I mean,
what was I supposed to do?
Fuck you made well.
Yes.
What were you supposed to do?
That's the dumbest fucking thing I've ever heard.
So then I go,
what do you need to do?
He told me when he did do I go,
all right,
you want to go down and do it?
Okay,
good to fight.
I mean,
he still did way too much.
Don't,
I don't know.
It was the weirdest fucking response ever.
Well,
you know what?
What was I supposed to do?
So,
but I was actually happy that I,
I mean I lost my shit on it now thinking about it on the podcast way more than I
did in the moment.
And um,
you know,
I said to the guy said,
I'm not trying to be difficult,
but you know,
that's what you're doing here is it's not right.
You know,
it's not,
I should have said,
oh,
I should've said that.
And you know,
it's not right.
You got impatient and he just said to hell with it.
I'm just going to do this anyways and you're trespassing.
You know,
you trespassing.
I don't care that your worked for the state.
That doesn't mean,
you know,
I guess you know,
if,
if my fucking house was on fire or they,
the pole or some shit,
there was a live wire hanging from it thing.
Yeah,
I guess you have the authority to go up and over.
I don't think you can do that just because you're fucking tired and knocking on
the door.
Nobody answers.
Okay.
Anyway,
sorry.
So I just got back from Phoenix,
Arizona.
I had a,
the best fucking time when I was out there,
ate a bunch of great food,
but all basically I kind of aid mainly down near,
um,
wherever,
wherever the fucking Phoenix Suns play the,
uh,
traveling Riverside resort arena,
whatever the hell they call it.
Um,
had a couple of really cool,
um,
meals when I was down there.
Went to this really good pizza joint.
Um,
good for southwest pizza.
You know what I mean?
Let's not get crazy here.
Right.
And,
uh,
got a good burrito down there.
I didn't work out at all.
I was driving over to see my dog.
I was starving.
I got to fucking whopper with cheese and fucking burger king and all freckles is
a,
that's it.
I'm done.
Um,
I'm officially,
I'm on the wagon for the first time in a year,
like really hardcore on the wagon.
Like I'm fucking done.
There's no drink in insight other than water for me.
Um,
I dunno.
I was,
uh,
I don't want to happen to me.
The last two times I went on the road,
I just spent under a fucking,
a lot of stress.
You know,
not sleeping with the kid.
And then I got to put this new hour together and,
uh,
my fucking shoulder is still messed up,
although I finally turned the corner with it.
And,
um,
but you know,
so I'm just,
you know,
I just haven't been able to work out the way I want to and I swear to God,
dude,
I am starting to get dad bod and I have to stop this immediately.
I am too God damn vein.
You know,
you don't want you to just look bad in a tee shirt.
I have a pothead body right now and I do not fucking like it.
Oh,
I forgot to tell you still have to deal with that guy.
Hey,
you know,
what the fuck was I supposed to do?
I come into my house and there's this strange odor,
like,
what is that?
Is that some hippie candle?
What's going on?
And I come downstairs and Nia tells me that a fucking pipe or some shit burst
the night before and all this water came out.
I go,
you gotta be shitting me.
You gotta be shitting me.
And I go,
okay.
Did you,
did you go to the front of the house like I showed you and turned off all the
water?
Okay.
No,
I turned it off under the sink.
I'm like,
Oh God,
okay.
I'm smelling water.
And then I look at my bedroom ceiling and there's a brown stain just ever so
small,
this little fucking crack.
And I was just like,
oh my God,
not again.
Please tell me not against.
So I run upstairs.
I shut off the main fucking thing.
You know,
this is this thing about these feminists.
They don't want to do fucking housework anymore,
but they,
they're not going to do the guy shit either.
Like no one had a shut the fucking water off.
It's like,
so what exactly are you going to do?
Well,
can watch Mary Tyler Moore reruns.
So it's,
I'm sorry,
whatever.
I'm flying,
uh,
run upstairs of flying out the fucking door.
I shut it off.
And then I,
you know,
now I got my stupid,
can I iPhone flashlight.
You know,
because the fucking guys outside checking the box and cut off the electricity,
the water's off.
Now this is just basically a glorified fucking log cabin and I'm going through
the crawl spaces and all this shit and I'm trying to find out where this water
is coming from.
Has It collected?
Is the ceiling going to collapse?
What is going on?
And um,
fortunately I think,
I think we're all right.
Um,
and it was also fresh water.
So I don't think you need guys like you don't have to deal with mold,
which I don't know if that makes sense to me.
I mean,
it doesn't also depend on what the fuck's in the inside the pipe.
I have no idea.
I'm sure there's going to be a bunch of people tweeting at me make scaring the
shit out of me.
So that's basically what I came home too.
But the plumber came by,
change the fucking thing that needed to be changed.
Hopefully everything's gonna be all right.
But I once again,
you know,
everybody in your house,
I'm telling you right now needs to know how to shut off the fucking water.
Everybody.
In fact,
that's the first thing I'm going to teach my daughter when she starts walking
around.
You know what I mean?
When she understands concept of water and what it can do to your house.
All right.
And I'm just going to be like,
look,
the next time a fucking,
I swear the next I'm going to get rid of this house.
I'm done with it.
Fuck this house.
I've had it.
Okay.
I've just had it with his fucking house.
You know,
it's my old Goddam faults would have when you buy a 100 year old fucking house
that has a lot of character,
you know,
okay,
I'm going to sell this fucking house and I am going to buy some brand new home
depot doubt.
No character whatsoever.
I mean,
I want it to look like a fucking food corn.
I don't give a shit as long as everything's brand new in it.
No,
don't mind like the people won't put it together.
Right.
And I'll still have the problems,
but um,
I was literally when I was in the crawl space.
Right.
Okay.
Tell these fucking cobwebs and all that.
I just,
it just,
it was it.
I officially fell out of love with this house and I was like,
you know what?
Fuck this house.
You know why?
You know you went house,
you fucking win.
You probably down.
Cool Hand Luke.
You finally fucking did it.
What's your dirt do?
Doing the boss man's hole.
That's what this house has been doing me the entire fucking time I've lived
here.
I Dunno boss.
We got to get it out of there.
What's your dirt doing?
The boss man's yard.
I don't know boss.
Yeah.
Ah Fuck.
Anyways,
homeownership,
you know they always show all the young couple on TV,
fucking smiling and all that shit.
They had a fucking show me my fucking
whopper with cheese.
Fucking body crawling around a goddamn crawl space.
Well of course.
What you're going to walk around across space bill.
Okay,
so then I fucking
thank God.
It's all right.
So then I leave,
I go down to take care of all the bills and all of this shit.
So why the podcasts late is late and I'm like,
all right,
I gotta I gotta pick up a salad or something.
I gotta start on the right foot here and uh,
you know,
typical la thing.
Oh,
this is a place I want to be.
Um,
that's a restaurant that,
you know,
40 people can eat at and there's four parking spots,
two of which are taken by the cook in the manager and the other two are taken by
the fucking wait staff.
So as always,
there's no fucking place to park.
And I turned the corner.
Lo and behold,
there's a fucking spot.
And um,
I went down and turned around like a gentleman and of course someone else said,
fuck that.
And they made the three point turn into the God damn parking spot.
Took my fucking pocket spot.
Okay.
And uh,
that,
and then I,
then that was it.
That was enough.
All my meditation,
everything went out the fucking window.
And uh,
you know,
so I had my first fucking meltdown in a while and weeks,
my first meltdown in weeks.
And then I basically,
I went from yelling at the guy who fucking took my,
took my parking spot.
It was my parking spot,
right?
He got there first.
I,
I saw it first,
but he fucking made a better move and he gave,
he boxed me up like,
you know,
he got the rebound.
Okay.
I went from yelling at bout him in the car to myself to yelling even louder
about the electrician to yelling even louder about shutting the fucking water
off.
The second is of God damn problem.
Um,
yeah.
And then I found a pocket squad and I got out
and I think I was yelling so loudly like somebody walking by was looking at me
all fucking weird and I,
I dunno,
whatever.
I had a little bit of a setback.
But uh,
anybody out there if you'd like to buy a house with a lot of character,
oh,
this is how this house is a character.
I'll tell you,
it'll have you scratching your head.
Um,
maybe I'll sell this.
I mean,
talk to me about this.
Maybe I'll sell this fucking house and we'll just do the,
do the,
uh,
moving is one of those soulless fucking high rises.
You know,
you know those things that people do.
The empty nesters do well,
they just don't want to deal with the fucking house anymore,
which I never understood.
It's like,
why the fuck would you want to?
We'd live in your house.
All the kids are out of there,
you know,
you know you've got all these spaces.
It's going to be great now.
Right now I know why.
Now I know why.
Okay.
Oh,
do I know why?
Cause this shit's going to happen.
Okay.
Yeah,
I,
I completely fucking get it now.
Like I don't give a fuck about a view.
I don't give a fuck about,
you know,
old school shit.
I don't give a fuck about anything.
All I give a fuck about is if something breaks,
it's not on me.
How,
where can I live like that?
I might go back to renting
this house is just,
it's just a fucking,
it's a motherfucker.
I'm never again,
I'm telling you right now,
don't have a buy a fucking old house unless you are handy.
You know,
or unless you just like making your life fucking difficult.
I'm telling you,
this is the classic,
this is what means versus you were laughing about all week was how he makes his
life easy.
I make my life difficult.
He buys a fucking house,
the last fucking guy,
three dead,
the whole thing he gets,
he turnkey.
I need to be more Versie.
I gotta I gotta I gotta I gotta fucking do that.
My next fucking place.
I don't give a shit what it is.
I'll buy a fucking Winnebago brand new though.
Just live in that right where bill,
you just don't fucking parking spots out here.
Okay.
I Dunno.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
so I'm going to be Billy elliptical head,
Billy fucking no booze bag and we've eaten salads and all this fucking shit and
I,
you know,
I got to get this under control,
disgusted with myself,
you know,
it's time to walk and the fucking bathroom mirror and just trashed myself,
take the shirt off.
Let's see what it is.
You know?
Okay.
It looked like Tom Brady.
I just first way in,
you know,
when he was a college student,
just eating Cheetos and he was like a third string quarterback or some shit.
Okay,
well I know it was like his face.
I look like his stomach.
Okay.
Just no muscle tone whatsoever.
I'm exaggerating,
but in me,
I don't know.
It's not a,
it's not what I want.
It's not what I want to say.
You know what I mean?
It's Christ.
It's like my belly is to the point is going to be like,
when I stand in the shower,
my knees aren't going to get it.
Wet
feet are totally dry,
you know?
Um,
but you know something,
I'm not that bad,
but that's the road I'm heading on.
And I was sitting on a plane today watching all these fucking people who just
destroy their bodies.
Just getting on the plane,
just getting on a fucking plane.
They're like winded from walking down that movable hallway,
whatever you call that.
It's not the tarmac.
When did,
what did they call that?
The jet way
people.
Could you put your coats under the seat in the overhead compartment so we can
expedite the boarding process.
We still have a lot of peoples standing.
I'm on the jetway.
We want to have an on time departure.
Um,
and I'm just sitting there watching all of these fucking,
you know,
just fat Fox walking by.
There's gotta be something amazing though
about living that way.
Okay,
well you're all,
you just always just,
you're always eating exactly what you want to eat,
you know?
Hey Mike,
you want a devil dog?
Yeah.
Do,
do you want to get a Burrito?
Sure.
Absolutely.
What do you feel like having a cheeseburger,
French fries and a chocolate malt.
Okay.
You know,
it's like you basically,
you're eating like a fucking eight year old whose parents aren't home your
entire life.
You don't,
you know,
when your parents took off,
that was it.
You went to the enemy,
you're eating a fucking Entenmann's cake.
Cause some donuts of those store bought fucking donuts.
Those ones where it was like,
it was like four plane for powdered for cinnamon.
Do they still make those things?
We had those things all the time.
I used to eat a goddamn at IAA,
absolute shit when I was growing up.
Okay.
Then you went outside,
you ran around and just burned it off.
You have a fucking blew out.
Your rotator cuff is a fucking seven,
eight year old you injury free brand new fucking car.
You know what?
My Body's like,
my body's like this house just fucking old as shit.
Yeah,
I can't wait.
You know how they can like grow an ear and I'd fucking petri dish now I swear to
God,
Ay,
I,
you know they got to do that.
Like
it's going to happen man.
When they stick they can borrow all the organs and they can grow all your
fucking body parts up over again.
I'm telling you right now,
it's going to be like,
your body's going to be like a a
I will,
you know it,
but they probably still would look old,
but it looks like one of those Resto Mod.
Thanks.
You know which brand new underneath.
But on top it looks at,
you know,
like in 1960 whatever is any of this fucking make it sense?
I mean,
what was I supposed to do?
I knocked on your door three times and there was nobody here,
so I just figured I'd walk in your fucking yard,
put a ladder up next to your house.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
Can you imagine if somebody did that at Ted Nugent's house?
How many fucking bows and arrows would that guy have?
And there's stupid construction hat.
Okay.
What do you get the hardhat on?
Fourth?
This is like,
like that's going to help.
Like when you fall off the ladder,
that thing doesn't fall off with you.
Maybe that's why he did it.
He had his hat so fucking tidy wasn't even thinking.
Um,
okay.
Anyway,
so I was on the road and last night,
um,
I missed a Celtics beat the Golden State Warriors.
Holy Shit.
I got that game tape.
They've got to watch that.
And the Bruins beat the fuck out of the Detroit red where they beat him up,
but they scored six goals.
Man.
Um,
that's to try weird Redwing so you know,
one of the original six,
they,
I mean they did,
they play in hockey town.
Everybody,
there's a town out there where you play hockey.
There's a town,
I know where the hipsters go.
Gold bedrock,
walnut,
twitch,
twitch.
Let me read some.
Um,
how many goaltenders by the way did Z,
cause I've watched the highlights.
It was every one of them was a bad goal or your defense just gave it away.
You know,
my condolences to the,
uh,
all the players on the red wings today.
I can't imagine how fucking horrific your practices.
All right.
Uh,
the Black Tux.
Oh,
you know,
I saw when I was in Phoenix I saw Reggie fucking mail.
It's fucking amazing.
You walked right by me and I just watched a waiting for an elevator.
I just kept thinking like that guy lit up the garden
turn around is spike Lee and made the choke sign.
And they just look,
he's just standing there waiting for an elevator.
Totally relaxed.
Totally.
She does need to talk shit,
right?
He's the shit that's Reggie fucking Miller hits at three steals the inbound pass
runs behind the three wasn't good enough to get them for two fucking hits
another three point or turns around and looks at fucking spike Lee does the
church in the garden?
I mean that's the,
it's fucking
okay.
Do you ever have to,
do any of you ever got to have to accomplish anything else after that?
If I ever did some shit like that.
Oh for God sakes,
if I ever did some shit that,
you know what?
I got to take this.
Hang on a second.
All right.
I'm back.
I swear to God it didn't have a fucking sense and have a fucking ads.
Yeah.
You know,
you don't say,
Gee Gee,
I just wish you could just for one day,
save one day of being a kid.
You know what I mean?
Just to go back for 24 fucking hours and not have to deal with this fucking shit
of being an adult.
Yeah.
Good fucking Lord.
You want that fucking phone call was about about some sort of fucking tax
abatement for some bullshit.
I don't even know what the fuck they're talking about.
You need to go onto the website and didn't give a fuck you,
I don't want to.
It's an abatement.
You'll get money back.
You know what?
Just fuck.
How about you just keep it.
If you just keep it,
can I just not fucking waste those precious second one a big fucking get.
What if a tree falls on me tomorrow?
Okay.
This is one of my last fucking days and I went to www.fuckingabatement.to
whatever the fuck.
I just don't care.
Sorry.
I'm in such a country mood.
I had such a great fucking three days.
You know what it is coming home and there's somebody on a fucking ladder you
don't even know.
Just walked into your goddamn house or your,
you're,
you're on your,
on your proper tie and then a pipe burst and yell and the powers that be don't
go fucking shit off the goddamn water and you've got a brown spot.
You know when you're sealing it up.
Actually a little salty.
What I'm saying?
I was talking about Reggie Miller,
right?
I was just saying,
if I fucking,
if I did,
what the fuck that guy did,
I would,
I would have that
playing on a loop on my phone.
Yeah,
right.
The video and I would just walk around holding it up as I walked towards other
human beings.
The be it,
you know,
to credible.
What the fuck that guy did.
Just standing there waiting for an elevator.
All right.
Let me read a little bit.
Do you get here for a little advertising it?
Oh,
the black Tux.
Everybody.
They're not selling any of these to that fucking guy from the,
uh,
the musical there,
right?
Whatever his name is,
Ryan Seacrest.
Uh,
the black Tux looking great for a wedding or a special event has never been
easier with the black tux.com with high quality rental suits and Tuxedos
delivered to your doorstep.
The Black Tux is giving guys a new way,
a new way to rent and get this.
The black Tux offers free home.
Try on,
she can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your event.
What kind of a fucking man?
Or is it fucking Tuxedo?
Months before an event.
How much is your wife nagging you that you agree to that shit?
Fucking 60 days.
Hey,
you know,
fuck a march madness.
We'll go to a wedding in May.
Do you want to try on some fucking Tuxedos?
Uh,
no I don't.
I,
I'd rather jump out the fucking window.
But what's the best part you didn't ask?
It's completely done online.
No trips to the Tux shop required the black Tux Dotcom.
Let you create your look or choose from tons of stylist selected outfits
starting at just $95.
These suits have a modern fit.
You know,
it's not like the old days where you fucking yanked up your pants and your
ankles was shown right.
And you did the Charleston.
Do you know people?
Did you know what people when they were doing that,
you don't want to,
you know what else they were doing?
They were building my fucking house.
Uh,
the Black Tux dot coms let you create your look and choose from tons of styles,
selected outfits starting at just $95.
This,
oh,
I already said that shit.
And if you have any questions or issues or issues,
Jesus,
they're going to fucking be a therapist.
They're expert customers.
Can team,
customer care team has your back every step of the way.
How much is the a Tuxedo and what I was five.
Um,
after ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before the event.
That's a full two weeks to try it on and make sure everything fits.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event is over,
just drop your rental back in the mail.
Gross shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that to get $20 off your purchase?
Visit the black tux.com/bar as the black tux.com/bar for your $20 off purchase.
You know,
I tweeted about this,
um,
does anybody know where people in the NBA get their tattoos?
Were 90% of them go to get their tattoos.
They did the highest paid of the four sports,
I believe at this point.
And it,
you wouldn't know it by looking at the tattoos,
Jesus Christ with the area codes and the hole,
the fucking highway signs,
you know,
I guess those could be cool if,
if you actually took the time to like,
I dunno where they get them done.
They,
they're,
they look horrible.
Um,
I don't have anything funny to say about it.
I'm just always watching NBA hoop and they just,
they're all,
everybody's scribbled all over.
You can't make out anything of what anything is.
It's just a bunch of fucking shit.
Like for an NBA guy,
we'll get a fucking tattoo of his baby's face on his neck.
Okay.
Then you got to look at that for the rest of his fucking career.
Yeah.
Open.
He's like that guy in the globe trotters.
It also wore fucking headband around his neck.
I remember that guy.
Whatever his fucking name was.
Anyways,
blue apron,
everyone,
blue apron.
Not all ingredients are created equal,
fresh,
high quality ingredients.
Make a real difference.
So it's important to know where your food comes from.
I would not want to know where that fucking whopper with cheese came from.
Talk about your personal experience with Blue Apron.
I've never fucking used it,
but I've got to use it now.
That's maybe that's how I'll get in shape.
You know?
I'll be like Oprah.
I love it Bro.
You know,
do one of those things and maybe I can have a giant fucking house.
It doesn't fall apart.
You know what?
I lie like potato chips.
Can anybody pinpoint the year?
She officially went insane.
She's just been famous too fucking long.
I think it just makes you go crazy after.
Well,
everybody's always excited to meet you.
They're always given you a fucking award.
There's no way to keep your feet on the ground and then you just think
everything you're saying is interesting or exciting to the fucking point.
You'll just scream something like,
I love
sitting in a giant fucking yard.
Every time I see her,
I'm just like,
what is she doing?
Chase is Christ Oprah.
Just go to a fucking hot dog stand.
You know?
Stand in line.
Wait,
you fucking turn and eat the thing.
Just do that every once in awhile.
Just fucking
who likes God case.
And he goes,
fucking
know her cult of women that just hanging on our every word,
just hoping maybe this complete stranger on TV.
She's the one that's going to make me happy.
I mean that,
that's the saddest part of watching one of those Oprah shows and even know she
does it anymore.
I'm just gonna pretend the show still on the fucking air was all those women
that sat in the crowd,
the fucking look of hope on their face.
You know,
I always wanted to see,
you know,
what they should have had next door was the sea of men that all those fucking
poor women were married to.
You know,
that fucking motley crew of insensitive,
constant never told them they were pretty or whatever the fuck they needed.
Whatever they needed,
they weren't getting there.
They would go down to the studio audience.
So just fucking sit there with that fucking
thank you ever watch one of those shows with is like 10 whores and they're all
fucking fighting over some nerdy guy and that look of hope they have,
if they're going to get the fucking,
you know,
get handed a slipper,
which means they're going to be there for another week,
whatever the fuck,
whatever it is they do,
they all had that look on their face.
Um,
do you know what,
as much as I'm making fun of Oprah,
I also like bread.
But no matter how fresh it is,
no matter how much I like it,
if someone was standing in a big yard yelling that it would make me
uncomfortable and it would take away from the experience.
You know,
it's gotta be weird to be part of her fucking staff.
Okay.
Just every once in a while,
just hear yelling random things cost dumb.
Okay.
Yeah,
I bet Steadman knows that a block that out,
Huh?
That's what she has those giant fucking houses.
She probably likes to sound the Echo,
you know,
she's like Rosebud level famous citizen Kane.
What the fuck was I to all blue apron,
everybody for less than $10 per month?
No per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to make delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each week.
All that blue apron culinary team surprise you.
That's an Oprah thing.
We got a culinary TPO.
Surprise you recipes are not repeated.
How bad is my act right now than I did it six times?
I can barely talk.
That's what's called having no jokes.
So what you do is you just scream your shit,
throwing it against the wall.
Some of the shit that came out of my mouth,
oh my God.
So my,
I made a reference to Whitney Houston drowning in a bathtub like that.
That's how desperate I am for fucking material right now.
Recipes are not repeated within a year,
so you'll never get bored.
Customize your recipes each week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several different options so you can choose what fits your needs
and there's no weekly commitment.
So you get deliveries only when you want them.
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less.
Blue [inaudible] freshness.
Guarantee promises that every ingredient in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or they'll make it right.
Check out this meant this week's menu and get your first three meals for free
with free shipping.
I'm praying to God they have a fucking they name of fucking ingredient cause I'm
going to scream it like Oprah.
Uh,
by going to blue apron.com/burn.
You will love how good it feels and tastes.
You'll love how good it feels and tastes to create.
And how much would Oprah kill this read to create incredible home cooked meals
with blue apron.
So don't wait.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook.
Want I love?
Two more.
All right,
blinds.com whether you want privacy or you jerk off during the day or just men,
or just want to make a room,
a little Taco.
You don't have to take out a second mortgage to get a brand new custom blinds
from blinds.com yeah.
Why are blinds?
Why are blind so expensive?
Um,
you can make over any room or your entire house just by adding new blinds and
that blinds.com and and blinds.com has made it easy.
Jesus,
Bill next,
please mention the talking points below.
Well,
yeah,
I mean just the next shit here.
I'm obviously going to read it after you've read that.
Then read this blinds.com.
Okay.
Bye.
Satcom makes picking out and ordering brand new custom blinds,
fast,
affordable,
and shockingly easy.
Holy Shit.
Are we done already?
Yeah.
They'll walk you through the measuring and installation every step of the way
and what they're 100% satisfaction guarantee.
If you meet a mistake,
if you make a mistake,
I should never do this on a travel day.
You don't.
Once they said a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee,
I immediately started thinking of fast times at Ridgemont high.
You know,
it's 700 a hundred percent satisfied.
I don't want to,
I want to read front Brad.
Mostly if you don't shut up when you kick 100% of your ass,
I'm sorry.
If you make a mistake,
measuring your blinds or pick the wrong color or screw anything up with your
order,
they'll remake the blinds for you for free.
You want samples?
They're free.
You like shipping,
it's free.
It's all built into the price somewhere.
There's a crying child putting all this shit together in a third world country,
but you don't need to think about that.
You just close those blinds.
He closed those blinds and you never hear him crying.
What a whatever your level of confidence in the following instructions,
what,
whatever your level of confidence in following instructions or even using a
measuring tape,
the design consultants@blind.com we'll get on the phone with you and walk you
through every step.
Oh my God,
that's gotta be the worst fucking job ever.
What do you do?
Uh,
um,
I,
okay.
Over the phone I talked people through putting blinds up.
Okay.
I find it really rewarding.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now when you're turning it,
are you seeing more of the outside or less?
Okay.
Well.
Okay,
then.
Then you want to turn it the other way?
Yeah.
Turn it the other way and then yes,
they'll close.
Are they closing?
You are seeing less of the outside.
Okay.
Do you have any more questions?
They'll answer your questions and even send you instructional videos.
However you want to interact.
You can't get this run.
You can get made to order custom blinds without paying custom prices only
online@blinds.com call to action.
Capital letters must read g two blinds.com and use promo.
Oh go.
There's no,
oh there.
Oh,
I thought that it was like some shit right there.
G to the motherfucking blinds.com there's no,
oh in the copy here.
Go to blinds.com and use Promo Code [inaudible] for 20% off.
That's blinds.com Promo Code [inaudible] rules and restrictions may apply.
See blinds.com for details.
I'm definitely going to see the details all of a sudden.
Don't know where there was rules and restrictions.
All right.
See Cell C Shao I have.
I've had funny feelings.
I've gotten funny luxe.
I've eaten funny smelling Sushi,
but let me tell you it.
Danilo's are is funny.
As c cells,
streaming libraries stand up television and original content,
especially not the Sushi.
Why do they try to write these funny?
Why would you do that?
Jesus Christ,
the George Burns right there.
Our next place.
Next please mention the following talking points.
I'm Kinda,
we see.
So you get unlimited access to CSOS original series next day,
late nights,
hilarious.
Standup specials.
I'm just not seeing the comments.
Comments today.
Binge worthy classics including 42 seasons of Saturday night live.
The entire Monty python catalog,
the it crowd and more.
We see,
so you get binge words.
The classics,
British called comedy original series like Ham and quest and bajillion dollar
properties.
Not to mention the entire SNL library.
We already mentioned it.
Stop saying,
not to mention you keep fucking mentioning how much stopped mentioning that
including the new episodes the day after they air plus CSO brings,
brings,
brings stand up who gave me the copy this week.
Two breaks plus CSO bring brings stand up right to your living room with
exclusive content from today's best comedians.
On demand and commercial free,
including Nick Depaulo.
He's got a killer special on them.
A sign up now,
the catch brand,
new standup specials from Jenna Friedman,
Fahim,
Anwar and Sasheer Zamata oh my God.
But the privileged white males here.
Um,
or watch your favorite sets from cus.
Comedians like Louis C,
k a me fucking
animal.
Paris.
Also Nick Dipaolo,
Scott one access.
See sells content from anywhere at any time using Ios,
android,
Roku,
apple TV,
Amazon fire TV.
Oh,
I just can't see the comments.
Windows or Xbox one.
Ready for the punchline.
CSOS just three 99 a month.
No joke.
Less than four bucks per month for all the comedy you want.
Anytime anywhere ad free.
Just go to Seeso,
s e s o Sierra,
Echo,
Echo Sierra,
oscar.com right now to sign up for two weeks for free with Promo Code
[inaudible] at checkout,
[inaudible] dot com spelled s e s l.com.
Promo Code Burr,
seeso.com Promo code birth.
Holy Shit,
I never thought that was going to end.
I honestly didn't think that that was gonna fucking end.
All right,
38 minutes of just absolute shit for this week.
People,
I apologize,
you know,
but I feel like for me that,
it was just some things that needed to be said.
All right.
I don't know what to talk about next.
Sorry.
I bitched about my house so much.
Enjoy this next little musical clip here.
Oh Hey,
by the way,
you know what?
I heard that uh,
that sneaker shit that I was saying actually ended up on some big sneaker
websites,
so I must be getting fucking trashed on that one.
You know,
I had no idea that,
you know,
I knew people were just sneakers.
I didn't realize I went and told him that much.
You know,
I actually bought a new pair of sneakers this week when I was out in Phoenix.
I got the classic fucking shell toes.
That's what I got.
You know,
cause a lot of people were suggesting that I wore those fucking,
you know,
you know those giant Chunky fucking sneakers that people with feet problem use.
You know,
I don't wear those.
Although I do have the Steve Jobs,
new balance,
you know,
if you look at it,
it's the Daytona 500 texture I believe I'm wearing,
I'm there.
I did have a nice pair of sneakers,
but I was not going to wear them to the Daytona 500.
So maybe I have a little sneaker head make,
right?
Maybe,
I don't know.
I wear the shittiest pair of sneakers.
I had to go to Alan,
that fucking track with all the God damn oil and shit all over the place.
Um,
once again,
I want to thank everybody that came out to stand up live.
Everybody at stand light.
It had such a great time and um,
I don't know,
Paul brosy crushed it and all week and uh,
I just had it,
I had a great time.
So thank you very much.
San Jose Improv in two weeks and uh,
that's it.
Please listen to the music if you'd like.
And uh,
we're going to have a greatest hit from a podcast recorded in a different time
in another year and something else.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You constant.
I'll,
I'll talk to you on Monday.
No.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's still burn Monday morning podcast 20 past nine on Monday morning and cloudy
day out here in La as it is the rainy season and a,
I actually have some guests over here,
so this is kind of be quiet,
kind of a quiet podcast.
Um,
cause I also have to do the,
uh,
I have some friends in town from out of town,
so we have to do all the La Shit.
Um,
and I gotta be honest with you,
I'm trying to think what the La should is because I'm still new out here.
You know,
when I lived in New York,
I knew what that meant.
You know,
that meant they wanted to go to the top of the empire state building.
They wanted to go to the Statue of Liberty,
uh,
Times Square.
Basically.
They wanted to go every place that a new Yorker never goes.
And,
uh,
so what my mission always was whenever I had,
um,
you know,
friends coming down to visit New York City was,
I immediately tried to convince them that all the things that they wanted to
see,
they didn't really want to see.
And,
um,
I like to think I was doing them a favor,
but,
uh,
you know,
part of it was selfish cause you know,
I'm not fucking getting on a boat to climb up into a statue that's looking out
into the ocean.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
you know,
I dunno,
he wanted to talk about underrated.
Overrated.
Okay.
Overrated climbing up into the statue of Liberty.
If you can even still do it with the whole nine,
America or whatever that we live in now.
I don't even know if you're allowed to fucking do it anymore.
I'm sure they'll let you if they like,
you know,
if you let them fingerprint you and scan your fucking retinas.
But,
um,
anyways,
I don't,
I always feel like when you go to a city,
like personally,
I,
you know,
I want to do a few tours the things,
but,
uh,
I want to hang out with the locals because they always know the good bars and
the restaurants and that type of shit.
Um,
so that's what I used to try to,
you know,
convince people like,
but it's hard sometimes.
Sometimes you just got to give him,
like when my parents came down and they wanted to eat at Mickey Mantle's on 57th
street,
59th Street and uh,
you know,
you just can't stop people from doing shit like that.
You know,
there's a great burger.
No,
no it isn't.
It's a gray is a touristy burger and it's fucking $18 more than it needs to be
because when you look out the window,
you can see central park.
What is wrong with you Mickey?
Mantle's yeah,
it's great.
Let's then,
let's go get a hot dog at Wade Boggs.
The fuck does Mickey Mantle know about making a burger?
Okay.
If you want to go boozing and Mickey Mouse.
Oh,
that's a low blow fucking dead legend.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
I apologize.
The Yankee fans over that when I shouldn't.
And sports fans in general,
you know,
making man,
I'll never did steroids.
Diddy,
granted they didn't exist back then and uh,
I got to tell you something.
It's too bad he didn't and it's too bad they didn't exist back then because we
would have got to watch that guy,
uh,
you know,
have the body of a 22 year old until he was 42.
And uh,
I got to tell you something man.
Um,
after,
you know,
just watching some of these guys get busted and you know,
getting busted for being on juice,
uh,
you know,
they always have that question,
should people who do steroids be allowed into the hall of fame?
And uh,
I think after the a rock thing,
I'm finally thinking,
no,
they shouldn't.
And just big for the simple fact that,
like I just said,
it's like it doesn't help you get better.
It just keeps your body in mint condition until you like 40,
42.
And all these guys who get busted the second they get off of them,
they have their numbers go right through the floor.
And I don't think it has anything to do with their skill.
It's just like a,
you do roids it's like you become one of the Eczema.
I'm not really big on those action movies and shipping and all those movies
where you know,
somebody get superhuman healing abilities and somebody slices into his arm and
it immediately heals up.
It's like you're literally doing the real life version of that.
And uh,
I don't think it's fair to guys like Ken Griffey Jr.
It really isn't like,
uh,
that guy quietly hit 600 fucking home runs and I,
you know,
kind of stop noticing 10 years ago when all these fucking gorillas will coming
up to the plate.
I Dunno,
I've said this before,
maybe they should have a special wing,
you know,
the roid rage weighing of the hall of fame.
I have no idea,
but I got to admit,
I think we're all hypocritical,
forgiven those guys shit because no one gave a fuck about baseball.
And then all of a sudden we're McGuire and Sosa came around.
I was one of the best years of baseball ever and uh,
everybody made a ton of fucking money and everybody had a great time and now
we're all acting like our feelings got hurt because we got to watch people hit
600 foot home runs.
You know,
that make any sense.
I'm half a fucking sleep out here.
Um,
here's something that I,
uh,
I actually read a quote from one of these magazines.
I guess evidently a Clint Eastwood was hyping that movie Grand Grand Torino.
I don't know if you guys have seen that movie.
I'm sure you've seen the ads for it.
Where he basically has I get out of might align you fucking person of another
race.
I'm a white man and I represented my car represents back when America was good
in the early seventies.
Um,
I guess when he was,
uh,
doing the interview for that movie,
he called I guess the current generation,
the pussy generation.
And at first it made me laugh and I'm thinking like,
yeah,
Clint Eastwood obviously has earned the right to call people pussies.
And I'm thinking,
wait a minute,
clinics,
where is an actor?
Okay,
who plays tough guys who never loses a fight?
Rarely any of it.
If he does lose a fight in a movie,
it's a fake fight.
So at the risk of making my second sack religious comment first trash in the
Great Mickey Mantle and now I'm going to go after Clint Eastwood.
Unlike where has Clint Eastwood I want,
this is my question for you guys this week.
Where's clinics would got off like where's he earned the right that he's this
tough guy cause like he plays a tough guy.
I remember understand that with like actors.
Like I remember like after nine,
11,
like um,
for some reason they wheeled out Tom Hanks and like that was supposed to make me
feel relaxed as an American.
And I remember during that time I was doing a joke on stage going and talking
about Tom Hanks saying he's done so many army movies.
He thinks he's a veteran.
You know what I mean?
It's not like you did army movies,
but he played an astronaut.
He was in saving private Ryan.
You know what I mean?
And like all of a sudden,
like,
he becomes like a,
all these guys,
like I said,
you know,
here's,
here's one 40.
I got fucking,
but you know,
friends out here.
So we're doing the touristy shit out here in La and I take them down to Mann's
Chinese theater or grooming's,
whatever the fuck they're calling it now.
And they got those,
uh,
they got the hand prints and the feet prints and the,
footprints there and the,
uh,
the cement.
And I found John Wayne.
I swear to God,
John Wayne had the smallest fucking feet I've ever seen.
I couldn't believe it.
This is the Duke John Wayne.
This is the guy.
Everyone was one.
Just thought if he even breathed on you,
he'd fucking knock you in the next week.
This guy had like,
I think he went to fucking lady gap to buy his cowboy boots.
He's like fucking
the smallest fucker things.
He could have fit both his boots and his cowboy hat.
That's how small his fucking Fida.
If you ever go to La and you,
you go to Mann's Chinese theater,
it's on the right hand side.
He had tiny little ass feet,
you know,
actors are fucking annoying.
You know what I mean?
So then they put on fucking leather jackets and they play these bad asses and
it's just like,
dude,
you're a fucking,
you're an actor.
Have you had any real fights,
Clint?
Ah,
somebody of a fucking rear engine.
The drive through at Burger King and he got out and you settled.
The score maybe has,
I don't know what,
but you know,
I don't know.
Fucking,
it just fucking annoyed me.
And moving on from that,
somebody actually sent me an email that kind of ties into this,
right?
I'm not saying clinics and a tough guy,
that guy is fucking ridiculous.
He's 80 years old.
He still lifting weights,
you know,
the way his eyes are squinted.
He definitely seems like a bad ass.
But you know,
I want to see his fight card.
I want to see his arrest record.
You know,
maybe he was a juvenile delinquent before he came up.
I don't know.
I haven't Wikipedia'd him yet.
I have no idea.
But this is just,
you know,
it's just an,
I don't even know why I'm defending this generation of people because I'm 40
years old.
So technically the only generation that pop culture gives a fuck about is the
young kids,
you know,
which is basically,
I don't know what,
whatever it starts to is basically once you're over the age of 24,
nobody gives a fuck about you anymore as far as like a what music you're
listening to.
Um,
anyways,
so this,
this woman wrote me this,
uh,
she wrote me this email and it said,
when it let me get down to the blah,
blah,
all this type of stuff saying really nice stuff to me,
which,
um,
I'm going to blow through here even though I totally appreciate it.
And she was commenting on the guy last week,
you know,
the guy last week,
I was reading the story where,
uh,
he was hanging with this girl,
most beautiful girl he's ever seen,
but she's dumb as a brick and as a fucking pothead and he can't figure out how
to close the deal with her.
Um,
so this is what she said.
She said,
Oh,
and about the guy who asked about what he should do with the,
with the pretty pothead girl,
ask them if you tried to get physical with her.
Um,
wouldn't he know whether or not she was interested in a physical relationship if
he had made a move on her,
which is a great point because maybe he didn't.
And she said he's probably one of those hesitant guys that want the check to
make the first move.
So typical of today.
So I guess that's kind of backend.
Clint Eastwood saying that this is like the pussy generation.
Um,
I don't want to be a dick here,
but I think a lot of that has to do with,
uh,
the oversaturation of a date rate movies.
And,
uh,
these 100% chick tone shows like fucking Oprah and all.
I mean,
they got you so fucking,
I dunno,
I dunno what it is.
They're Gunna,
everybody's so convinced that women aren't the same lying sacks of shit that
guys are with just different genitalia that I think a lot of guys are
approaching,
um,
stupid pothead shakes like they're these princesses that need to be rescued.
In other words,
what I'm saying is he,
she had just fucking bender over,
he should just stick her bag of weed on the floor in front of our ankles and
when she bends down to get it,
he should handle this business.
All right.
That was ignorant.
There you go.
That's the first a straight up fucking ignorant statement of the week.
Um,
what's going on with it here?
This is the out of the Monday morning podcast.
If you're wondering what this babbling is,
um,
I do one of these every single week.
It's like fucking cal Ripkin on the cal Ripken a fucking podcast.
I can't remember the last time I missed one.
Even when I fucking miss one,
I call up and I apologize,
you know,
does that count if cal Ripkin missed a baseball game in the middle of his
streak?
And he just kind of called in the Orioles and said,
yeah,
sorry about that.
Yeah.
But he called up.
He called up before the sixth inning,
so that counts.
It's him showing up.
Anyways,
I do one of these every week.
People send me a,
they send me questions,
they send me their list of underrated,
overrated.
Um,
sometimes they ask me for advice.
Sometimes somebody sends me a country email and a,
they earn the right of a Douche bag of the week.
If it's bad,
if it's bad,
a criticism of I deserve it,
I'll take one on the chin.
Um,
and also why hyped the stuff that I have going on in my career.
Okay.
Bill,
what do you have going on in your career this week?
Well,
I will tell you on,
uh,
next Monday,
Monday the,
uh,
the fuck is today and Dan this phone once the nine plus seven,
the 16th,
March 16th,
I am going to be doing,
um,
a couple of shows.
I believe they added a second show at the punchline in San Francisco.
First one sold really well.
And last I heard we were going to add a second show.
Um,
you can go to a punchline comedy club.com.
I have all the information.
I probably don't even have that up on my website.
Do I?
What a moron.
I'm going to do that at the end of this podcast.
By the time you hear this,
it's going to be up there hopefully.
Um,
I'm going to be at the punchline San Francisco next Monday night with Joe
Barton.
Nick,
um,
and the shows are at seven o'clock and I believe they just added a nine or a
nine 30.
And that's what I like to do.
I'd like to hype Shit where I have three quarters of the information and later
on this month,
the final weekend of March,
whatever the hell those dates are,
I'm going to be at the house of comedy and East St Louis White people.
Don't be scared.
It's going to be a nice mixed crowd,
you know,
and you know,
just like our president nice and mixed,
you know,
they'd go,
let me bring in America together.
Um,
and then I got up after that I got,
uh,
the Trump marina.
What do I get on my fucking website here and figure out that most of you
listening to this,
by the way on my website,
cause I gotta I gotta admit I'm starting to find my space,
my space.
I'm starting to feel like the survivor of a nuclear holocaust,
you know,
kind of like will Smith's character in I am legend every day.
Every Monday I will be doing a podcast.
It's the pier down at the bottom of Manhattan,
you know,
and wants to saber tooth tiger.
I never understood those fucking lions in that movie.
Where the fuck did they come from?
You know the only lions in Manhattan or in the zoo.
So if everybody,
the zookeepers all died of whatever fucking disease it was,
was that some animal lover who came up with the end of the world?
Rabies,
I have to let these lions go and get mauled to death just like you fucking
deserved.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
Sorry.
I had to do that until I got to my website.
Um,
April 4th,
2009,
I will be at the Trump marina with uninformed Joda,
Rosa comedy central presents Joe de Rosa,
every local bar and Manhattans Joe to for rose.
Sorry Joe,
if he listened to this,
like,
you know,
good things come in three and you only have two good things in your life.
All right?
And I'm one of them.
Don't ever forget that.
You fucking half Egyptian jackass.
Alright,
I'm getting a little louder for the more angrier.
Um,
what else do I got?
I got the funny bone in Columbus and my Caroline's date got moved from the
middle of May to the last week of April slash first weekend.
I guess it's the first weekend in May.
All right.
I'm sure I'm going to emails on that.
Oh my God,
I was coming in from Chattanooga just through your show.
Send me a free DVD.
I will,
as long as you open your mouth and let the mailman jam it down your fucking
throat.
I
really getting me here.
Um,
oh,
we're going to be getting less than the girlfriend over there.
She puts a fucking makeup on.
Okay.
Audience of one.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
oh,
here we go.
You know,
it's uh,
something that really annoys the shit out of me.
Uh,
parents,
I don't like former Fred Boyd,
date rapists to then have kids and then sit there and,
and you know,
now because they have a kid,
I have to be respectful around them.
I think I talked about this last week,
but I'm going to talk about it again because it's happened again.
I'm sick of you form a fucking loud douche bags,
you know who just ruined people's flights.
You ruined baseball games basically.
You like me?
Okay,
you're an asshole.
And now that you have a kid,
everyone else has to be on their best behavior because you ended your life.
And the fun in your life.
Everyone else has to be on your schedule,
all right?
Fuck you and your fucking kid,
If you don't want them to be around a fucking animal like myself,
don't take him out in public,
okay?
That's what they have board games for.
So why don't you sit there with your board game and you dip in re your
turtleneck sweater that you don't want to wear as the rage for the person that
you knocked up,
builds up inside of you want.
Don't you keep that all right.
Walk out your back yard and scream into a bush.
Okay?
But leave your fucking kids at all because I'm still single.
I don't have any kids and I'm having a good time and I'm not having you be a
fucking wet blanket because you have this little creature that only half looks
like you.
All right?
Okay.
Coming up swinging.
Um,
all right.
I'm plated a crowd right now.
I'm getting laughs on just fucking deliberately being an ass hole.
I'm really not in that bad of a mood.
I'm not singling,
you know what I mean?
I'm not married either.
All right.
So watch your p's and q's over there sweetheart.
Um,
let ever tell you I got my girlfriend,
they gay,
his little fucking,
I want to put my makeup on.
I'm a little eight year old princess.
Women love that Shit and you know,
and you'd think it would keep them from heckling you during a podcast,
but it doesn't.
The fucking happiness only lasts for a few days.
All right,
question number one.
Okay,
so if you new to my podcast,
I do a,
and this one is going to be a little short this week.
I know,
I always say that.
And then I ended up doing 50 minutes,
but uh,
I'm already up to 18 minutes.
I'm going to try to keep this,
uh,
can I try to keep this about 30 minutes?
Oh,
by the way,
I went down to Irvine last night and I watched a,
my old friend from the Chappelle show,
Charlie Murphy to a,
a nice hour's worth of killer material that I haven't seen before.
Um,
if you get a chance,
definitely check out Charlie.
I think he really has a,
a
just a totally original,
original fucking style.
That's great.
He just goes up there and he tells these fucked up stories either that happened
that he invented hybrid stories that are partially true.
I don't even know what the fuck he is.
It was great.
I sat there in the crowd like a God damn fan and had a great time.
Um,
and that is it.
So look at me hyping up,
click the live,
whatever.
Fucking great guy.
I am.
Granted,
I already hype my shows and buried his hype fucking 20 minutes into a podcast
and I'm patting myself on the back.
Um,
all right,
I do questions.
I answer questions every week here on the podcast.
So here are some questions.
Hey Bill,
I was wondering if you ever had a slow,
slow,
a slow spot and comedy,
like if you ever had a period of time when you didn't come up with any material,
any material for awhile.
Oh yeah.
That happens all the time then it happens like every six weeks,
you know,
or whatever.
Oh,
we'll have for a six week period.
But,
um,
I've learned how to get,
I've learned what works for me,
how to get me out of those.
And I think I've answered this before,
but I know I have a Zillion podcast so I will answer it again in the name of
comedy.
Um,
what I do to get myself out of those,
I take all rules of,
of being a hack.
I just throw those out the window and um,
I'm really setting myself up to get trashed.
Like really,
Bill,
I never noticed that you ever,
uh,
didn't take the rules of hack off with your awful specials.
Um,
no,
I just,
basically I do two things when I'm in writer's block.
A,
I will talk about current events like that dumb,
broad,
but the eight fucking kids and just basically shit that bike every comic is
jumping on,
you know,
like you ever see when an animal dies and the discovery channel is a bunch of
vultures sitting around it.
That's kind of like hack materials.
Like,
and I'll fucking fly right down with my ugly buzzard head and I'll take a big
chunk out of it.
I basically just basically if you're in writer's block just to Hacky shit about
topical new stuff.
And also I try to ask my self what's bugging me right now?
Anything from,
um,
my girlfriend.
It's got a bad look there.
My girlfriend too.
Uh,
like,
um,
the fact that I can't come up with any new material,
anything that's bothering me.
And um,
I just,
you just kind of use that as an exercise just to go on stage and just to be
saying something new,
even though you know it's hacky shit that you're never going to keep it,
it's still feels good to not be doing all the jokes that he is sick of.
And usually they'll end up spinning into something else hopefully.
And you kind of pull yourself out of the mud and uh,
and if all else fails,
just pick on some fat guy in the crowd.
All right,
now don't do that.
Don't do that.
Okay.
It didn't we learn anything from Eddie Murphy in,
uh,
the clumps whenever the fuck that more than,
what was that movie called?
The night professor.
You know what?
I fucked up.
I thought I had all the questions right in a row.
Now I've got to scroll down.
Hey,
how did you guys enjoy the music last week?
Cause you don't like the old school music.
I'm going to play some more and we play you a Ted Heath elks parade next week.
This is slowly just going to become like fucking pirate radio.
I bought two more records this week.
I actually bought a clash record cause I felt really bad about trashing them,
not trashing them,
just saying I didn't understand that music.
So I deliberately went out and I bought a bunch of music that I never fucked
with when I was a kid cause I uh,
I got into ACDC which led me into Motley Crue,
which led me then down to a really bad road of Glam hair metal
that I want to say and it would Britny Fox.
But somewhere in there though I did,
I did.
I found Stevie Ray Vaughan when he did the video for,
couldn't stand the weather.
So I always had one foot in decent music.
But uh,
basically I totally shut out the Ramones or the clash.
And lets you know other than their radio shit,
Elvis Costello,
this is all shit I bought this week.
I finally downloaded a David Bowie that uh,
Ziggy stardust album and I was like,
you know,
this is like one of these great concept albums that people listen to in the 70s.
And I was like,
fuck this,
I'm doing it the way they did it in the 70s minus the drugs.
So I got my headphones that I have,
I do have headphones,
I have the big fucking,
you know,
but actually for drums they kind of protect the ears from the drums.
And he also couldn't listen to your iPod,
which I don't have my dismay.
And I plugged it in my laptop and I listened to the album and I fucked up was
cause rather than listening to it in the track order,
I guess on my iTunes,
I had it in last downloaded.
So it kind of jumped all around the album.
I kind of realized when Ziggy Stardust fucking killed himself or whatever,
by the third song,
I'm like,
wow,
how's David Bowlby going to pull itself out of this fucking thing?
And then I realized,
you know,
once again I fucked up with technology but the fucking killer album and uh,
I don't know if anybody has any suggestions of,
of music from that era.
You know,
all the shit that I thought sucked,
like talking heads,
I kind of liked a couple of their songs,
but like some David Burns Solo Shit I've found is amazing.
And to think that I was in a,
in a warehouse
just trashing him during that period of my life,
thinking that he sucked as I was listening to Cinderella
and poison and all this,
uh,
Tesla,
I'm not saying they were bad,
but that was definitely the smooth jazz of heavy metal.
It was John.
I,
it's just fucking
embarrassing.
Really embarrassing.
I think eighties music really gets a bad rap when you start listening to,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck.
I just literally asked you for advice then and then I bought a couple albums.
All right.
I actually literally still by him too,
by the way,
bought a couple of cds and didn't even listen to them yet.
And now I'm already trying to tell you guys what's good music from the eighties
TDC,
the fucking the Moose.
The inner Mussolini
fucking in me.
I Dunno.
I'm not.
All right.
Um,
let's get to underrated overrated here or what?
You guys want to hear a story about revenge?
Uh Huh.
I like I asked you guys questions.
You know,
it's like you actually have to say,
and as you sit there and nod your head and your cubicle,
yeah,
yeah.
You know,
or pump your fist on your fucking treadmill.
or just say yes out loud,
loud,
loud in your middle seat on that Delta Airlines flight you on Delta Airlines
right now.
Is there somebody with bad breath eating pistachios next to you?
If ever,
tell you that fucking story and real and he's eating the red ones too.
That made his lips all fucking pink by the end of her Rick.
Horrific flight.
All right,
let's get to the revenge.
When the fuck is it?
Pussy generation.
I'm really disorganized this week.
Okay.
Because I have guests.
I have,
I'm entertaining this week,
Erin,
than wearing a Tuxedo for three days.
Underrated.
Overrated.
Overrated
with fuck is the revenge story.
God dammit.
This is embarrassing.
I don't want to just read it.
I'm just going to start.
I'm just going to jump around.
Who's at House of pain?
Uh,
no.
Well the fuck.
Oh fuck you.
I don't know who it was.
I tapped out during that period too.
All Movie Review Bill.
I just got back from the midnight showing of the watchman.
I really don't know how to review it.
Untold,
it sticks pretty close to the graphic novel and had cool special effects,
great story and good acting.
But I kind of felt eh after it,
after leaving the dark night.
I remember,
I so amazed.
I didn't have a single thought run through my head for at least five minutes
after ironman and hulk.
I left feeling satisfaction.
But with this movie it's something just kind of left me feeling depressed after
watching it.
I think it was the overall message of the movie was serious told in a totally
ridiculous way.
Anyway.
Anyway,
I would recommend it.
But go with caution.
If you don't like comic books and have trouble following fragmented,
fragmented storylines like Tarantino movies,
I wouldn't go.
And I said,
God damn good review.
Got Right to the fucking meat and potatoes of it.
Oh,
and by the way,
he says it was directed by the guy who did the 300 story,
300 movies.
So there's as a lot of man ass in it.
Yeah.
I find that funny.
That guys really liked that.
Uh,
that movie 300.
I mean,
I thought it was pretty ridiculous,
but um,
the amount of guys that get pumped after they see that,
I mean,
that literally was playgirl the movie.
I thought,
um,
I just thought the whole thing was stupid.
They sparked us.
I mean,
good luck with that.
Um,
you know what that's like.
That's like Beyonce and girlfriend downloaded that fucking album.
The name of the album is I am dot,
dot,
dot.
Sasha fierce.
All right,
Beyonce.
Well,
good luck with that character.
He kind of still sound like Beyonce.
If you ask me.
Beautiful,
gorgeous woman,
woman.
Really condensed.
But her voice,
oof,
Jesus Christ,
horrible,
punishing you,
just fucking Polish into her.
Best thing was when she whipped her head around and fell down on the stage.
That was probably one of the greatest things I think I've ever seen.
And a lot of it's just bitterness.
She's just absolutely gorgeous.
You know,
she's totally out of your league.
And is there anything funnier than seeing a beautiful girl just fucking fall
right on her ass?
You know,
this is ridiculous.
I'm sure she's a nice fucking person,
but you know,
I should really,
reality is,
I'm kind of thinking like,
this is Jay z's fucking wife.
And uh,
then he stabbed somebody one time for something,
although he did it in a hacky way.
He walked up and he used the godfather line.
He said,
you broke my heart and then stab them.
That's all alleged.
Why don't I shut the fuck up?
Okay.
I will.
All right,
here's the revenge story.
Bill.
I'm not really into revenge,
but if someone fucks with me to the point where I think about pushing them off a
cliff,
then yeah,
I kind of feel like I have to do something.
So here's my story.
Oh,
this is a good one.
Settle in for this one.
If you're at home,
get underneath your Afghan and rose some fucking marshmallows because this is
like a,
this is the closest thing to a ghost story.
Um,
this is just has that evil fucking,
uh,
last house on the left Vibe,
um,
which I love that they're making.
Again,
that reference will finally make sense to people.
If you don't know what that is.
There was a genre of films in the 70s,
which were basically rate movies.
Last house in the left,
gator bait.
Fucking,
uh,
I spit on your grave and evidently they're going to make a comeback,
which I think is fucking hilarious,
you know,
we haven't had a good rate movie in awhile.
All right.
Um,
let's remake last house on the left.
I think that that needs to be updated.
All right.
Anyways,
Bill,
I had a girlfriend for about three years.
This is the revenge story.
Bill.
I had a girlfriend for about three years who ended up cheating on me when I
found,
and when I found out about it,
I called her out on it and she got defensive and turned on me,
blah,
blah.
While do I,
that's,
that's some pretty,
uh,
she's got skills.
If she was able to do that,
uh,
you cheated on me.
You fucking bitch.
Yeah.
Well you never do the dishes.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I guess you made a good point.
How the fuck could she turn on you unless you,
all right bill,
just shut up and read the story.
Okay.
I will.
So anyway,
she turned on me,
um,
and he goes,
I made the poor decision and took her back about a year later,
about a year later,
she cheated on me again and I told her to go fuck herself prior to the second
cheating,
I bought a trip to Disney world for us about eight months after we broke up,
it was time for the,
for the Disney world trip.
So I asked her if she wanted to go see,
she said yes,
and off we went.
Now my revenge kicks in.
See,
this is just like one of those movies starts off all nice and sunny.
We go into the camp,
we're going to Disney land and here comes fucking Jason on a crystal lake.
Um,
so now my revenge kicks in.
All of the degrading things I've ever wanted to do.
This chick I did to this one.
Okay.
And I have guests,
so I get a mumbled his shit.
I busted on our face.
I pounded her into the ass until she puked Jesus Christ.
Women are just literally ripping their headsets off right now.
Anyways,
he goes,
it was fantastic.
On the fourth night we had an argument,
she told me that she wanted to go on this trip to try and win the back cause she
felt bad for all the things she had done to me.
Basically she was apologizing for cheating when I told her that there was no
chance of us getting back together.
And the older only reason why I fucked her was to make her feel like a
prostitute.
She bought a plane ticket home and I felt wonderful.
I guess what I'm trying to say is some people deserve what they get.
Oh God,
what a great,
great story.
Um,
there's so many levels to,
okay,
first of all,
just the fucking,
the fact that she cheated on you and you took her back.
He just liked de Niro's character and casino,
you know what I mean?
You didn't know how to handle it.
And then she cheats on his second time and then you just become jaded and you
just go into like a,
it was like,
you know those movies where the guy,
you know,
the,
the week person's just getting the shit kicked out of them and then finally they
just can't fucking take it anymore.
And then all of a sudden they turn into like fucking like Clint Eastwood
character.
You actually did that with this girl.
And then the whole other level that I love.
Okay.
Is that now that you've finally found in this skank in bed the way she always
wanted to,
probably the reason she cheated on you.
You know,
cause you probably would do in the,
I love you kind of sex now.
You actually fucking do what you were supposed to be doing with this girl.
Now she wants to get back with you.
Fuck that.
She didn't go to Disneyland because she wanted to get back with you.
She went to Disney land because she's a fucking cunt who saw a free tip to
fucking Florida and she thought she was going to play you again and get more
shit out of you.
Then all of a sudden you come in there and you throw down like Johnny fucking
Wad and now all of a sudden meant then.
Then she wanted to get back with you and then you told him to go fuck herself.
Which was perfect because I thought you were going to crumble in that moment and
you didn't,
you know,
and then she fucking left and then that's great.
And then you laughed your ass off and jumped on the tea cups listening to,
it's a small world after all,
you know,
that's fucking great.
Four stars.
If you fucking film that,
I would,
not only would I go see it,
I would buy it on DVD,
Kuwait fucking story.
Revenge.
Um,
all right.
And we go,
oh,
he had a lot of passion in it,
Huh?
Oh,
we're all we up to 34 minutes.
All right,
let's hustle through this.
Alright.
Overrated.
Underrated lists for the week.
High priced Mexican food.
You can get the same shit for half the price.
Cross the street.
You know,
some shit is written so perfectly,
I don't even need to add to what exactly 100% correct.
I still had to add to it are underrated.
Fake boobs.
Fucking awesome.
Um,
I like how that's written so short and it's just up to me to draw my own
collusion,
my own conclusions.
Fake boobs.
Fucking awesome.
Um,
have you ever touched them?
The fucking horrific.
Um,
personally,
I,
you guys,
I fake boobs are the worst.
Uh,
don't ever do that.
Don't ever do that.
Then all of a sudden in a matter of how good they are,
it's like you're having sex with a fucking cyborg.
I,
one of those awful Bruce Willis movies,
remember those,
uh,
or judge dread,
you know,
those movies where,
they,
they always end up hooking up with some half person,
half robot.
That's what I feel about that stuff.
And I really don't understand why people get face lifts and stuff,
you know,
first of all,
it doesn't look good and everybody noticed even if even if you didn't notice for
some reason when you get your face lift,
it also becomes really shiny.
Can anybody explain what that is?
Is that the botox,
what is it about getting faceless that makes you face so fucking shiny and it
literally looks like laminated?
Um,
now,
you know,
it looks like it looks like the apples and the grocery store that they spray to
make them really,
really shiny.
Speaking of which you ever get an organic apple?
I mean it's like so natural.
There's like a fucking warm in it.
I like the,
I think I like the old shiny wants.
Um,
all right.
They'll love your podcast.
Just wanting to say,
I think using,
I like this one to a bill.
I just want to say,
I think using big words is overrated.
If you can express something by saying a simple,
normal word,
why use a big word?
I just broke up with my girlfriend today and earlier she had called me anthro,
anthro phobic because I don't even know what the fuck that means because I don't
like,
cause I don't like her friends.
So she called me anthro phobic cause I don't like her friends.
Um,
I just don't like most of her friends.
It doesn't mean I hate people in general or even hate or friends.
I honestly didn't know what it meant.
So I looked it up.
It means a fear of people,
which isn't even what she said.
You're right.
She didn't even use it correctly,
are actually what she or she has a delusional view of her friends that her
friends represent everybody or that her friends are so great that if you don't
like them,
then you just hate all people because her friends represent humanity.
Jesus.
Good movement.
Dumping that fucking stuck up to what?
Um,
anyways,
I definitely do not like a lot of people,
but I don't hate people unlike that call last week.
Who Mess with that guy's mom?
Mom's car.
Yeah.
That guy was fucking nuts.
Anyways,
it seems like a,
you're kind of the same way.
I just don't see the point of using big words other than trying to sound smart.
It's like if something can be said more easily and in a way that's easy,
more easily understood by using smaller wood,
words can't even fucking read.
Especially if you have an idiot like me reading it.
Keep the word small.
Would you say something like that?
Seriously killer was,
I can't even see,
I didn't know what this word is.
Dak gnome.
ADAC no maniac or that serially was obsessed with killing.
I don't think you'd say either.
I think you just say that guy's a serial killer.
I mean,
I think we know what serial killers do.
I know what you mean.
Do I know what you mean by this is what I think.
I think,
I think big words,
uh,
they're,
they're much better in print.
You know what I mean?
Cause you don't want to read a great novel and it just have someone like,
dude,
shit was fucked up.
You know,
I was like,
damn,
I mean I wouldn't want to read.
Like I don't,
I don't mind.
I don't mind big words,
but I mean
they have to be coming out of the right person's mouth.
In fact,
I kind of liked them on some level when,
um,
you know,
but person use a big word and it makes me want to read and they're actually
using it in an obnoxious way and they've earned the right to use it that way
because they actually do read and don't watch TV.
But yeah,
if it's just some chick you were dating who has cunty friends and they watch the
Osi every Thursday night and then she pulls out a word like that,
um,
that sounds like that there was a breakup word.
She was like,
I'm going to use a big word here so I can feel like I'm above this guy who's
dumping me because my low self esteem is,
is,
is gonna fucking flow right over the side.
And I'm going to break down and I'm going to start crying and I'm going to have
a snot bubble and I'm going to feel horrible and I know in six months I'm going
to realize this person isn't worth crying about.
So I'm going to use a fucking big word here to try to save myself.
I really forgot what I was saying halfway through that.
That's weird.
I actually agreed with that guy and then in that scenario just sorta trashed him
like saying he wasn't worth,
he was,
wasn't what's crying over you know what?
I don't know shit about either one of you,
but uh,
you wrote me the letter so I'm going to fucking side with you.
I'm trying to be more balanced because I've trashed chicks twice in this.
Uh,
all right.
Hey Bill,
I've been a big fan of yours since I saw you.
I just feel it's funny.
I was wondering,
when are you going to come to the punchline in Atlanta?
Well,
why don't you go on my fucking website and scroll down and look for punchline in
Atlanta?
That's usually a good way to find out.
When I'm at the punchline in Atlanta,
I'm there in June.
Why do I put my dates up?
You know,
you know why?
Because 90% of you actually read the calendar and this fucking guy is not going
to listen to this podcast and he's going to email me again this week and you
know what?
I'm actually going to send them an email because I'm a whore.
I'll tell him the exact dates and put a link on it so I'm just going to shut up.
Um,
anyways.
all your shit is lit up man.
So,
um,
anyway,
overrated,
underrated,
overrated.
Having kids.
Marriage is bad enough,
but for the life of me,
I can't understand why the fuck anyone would ever want to have kids.
Your life effectively ends when you have kids.
Everything you do has to be for them.
How fucking pathetic is your life that you have,
um,
that you decide,
you know,
what would be fun?
Never having any fun anymore.
I can't wait to clean shit out of some douchebag.
Infants,
Asshole,
Jesus Christ.
Only get four hours of sleep a night.
If I'm lucky it never have any fucking fun with my friends ever again.
I mean,
Jesus fucking Christ.
Are you kidding me?
Um,
underrated.
This is the same guy maker's mark whiskey.
Let me guess what you talk about after you've had a couple of belts from that.
Anyways,
he says,
this shit is all I drink and it's fucking spectacular.
Under 40 bucks a handle,
80 proof and smoother than James fucking bond.
Ah,
this guy's great.
This guy is like the guy's guy and he's the guy.
You know what I love about this dude?
This is the kind of guy when you're in a bar and you know you're fucking up your
life,
which is why you go to the bar and you start drinking and this is the guy who's
going to tell you when your shit face that everything you're doing is exactly
right.
He's the guy who comes up.
What's the matter man?
Ah,
I don't know man.
I blew with this chick and he's the guy that you put her with this chick.
What the fuck is wrong?
You don't want to be with some fucking broad when you already have fuck fucking,
they just build you up and then you get hammered.
You get a Dui and then they take your shoe laces and then you curl up on that
burlap sack they use for a blanket and you wait for your dad to come down and
pick you up.
You know?
But in that moment,
before all that shit happens,
it's,
this guy's the shit dude.
You know what it is.
I think as you get older,
like me,
I'm starting to really feel like I want to have a kid now because it gets
pathetic after awhile,
you know?
I Dunno.
I Dunno if it's the,
the magnetic pole of the herd,
you know what I mean?
Everything has like a gravity to it.
And I think that as much as you tried to fucking escape the orbit of the fucking
heard,
you get pulled back into it.
And,
uh,
I don't know.
Sometimes I feel like I'm having too much fun,
like as a 40 year old guy and I'm sitting there,
you know,
learning how to play good times,
bad times.
And I got the NHL package and when I'm not watching TV,
I'm learning how to play ACDC songs.
So when I'm not doing that,
I'm fucking telling jokes on stage.
It just gets to the point you like going,
like you said,
you start feeling guilty,
you know I ain't guilty,
but you just start looking like,
you know what,
I need to fucking teach someone else how to do their life like this.
You know,
I got to admit I am a miserable motherfucker,
but I am having,
I'm having a great time and you can have it too if you learn how to talk about
your Dick onstage.
All right,
last thing,
Bill,
you started talking about the police last week and it got me thinking about
them.
Uh,
the band,
the police,
all this summer I was talking about all the,
uh,
all the music that I missed out on the police are one of the few that I listened
to.
Um,
anyway,
you started talking about them.
And so it pulled me out,
made me pull out some of my old records and I started listening to them.
Um,
and his underrated for the week,
as he said,
staying is a very underrated bass player.
Most of the baselines he plays are amazing.
I know most people think of him for his solo work and all the crappy new age
stuff he does,
but when he was with the police,
um,
he could rock a base like no other.
Uh,
yeah,
I got to met.
He's fucking,
um,
I would definitely,
I don't know if he is underrated and that with musicians he isn't.
But I think with people he's underrated because a lot of people feel that,
yeah,
a lot of his solo stuff is cheesy.
And meanwhile he's playing with some of the bet like Vinny Uda and all these
fucking guys.
And then I make a HUD that sounds like really lane that,
that field,
the gold song,
whichever it was like people think is like elevator music has him on base.
And I think Vinny call you to actually playing on drums.
Um,
all right.
I'm a music nerd.
All right.
And,
uh,
and that's it.
It's 10 o'clock out here and I have to go,
uh,
I gotta go do some touristy shit.
So,
uh,
you guys,
I really want to thank you for continuing to write in the questions to the end
of the age old red.
You guys.
You know,
it's funny,
you guys are getting so good at the shit that,
uh,
the podcast I think of becoming better.
I'm actually reading out loud and much better way you guys actually using
punctuation and,
uh,
you telling me some great stories.
I'm loving the stories about revenge.
Um,
and if you just want to comment on revenge and general,
cause,
um,
I,
you know,
I dunno.
Revenge really.
Uh,
that's a line that I,
I,
I've never,
I just don't,
I just don't cross that.
I just,
I feel like that is the deepest,
darkest part of your soul that you can go into.
You know,
you're fucking,
uh,
you know,
you like,
you like Jimmy Smits on Dexter.
Do you guys watch desks,
Dexter this season?
I'm gonna recommend a couple of shows Dexter I liked,
but,
uh,
you gotta watch brotherhood,
showtime on demand.
You have to watch that fucking show.
And uh,
it's just an unbelievable show and is actually,
there's a,
there's a couple of guys,
the first season comedian Tony Vee that,
that I learned so much from.
And another guy actually started out with,
uh,
Kevin Chapman who plays Freddy Cork,
who's one of my favorite characters on that,
on television right now.
Um,
I don't know if you just did the Gangsta fucking shows.
It's,
it's the shit.
It's a great fucking show brotherhood.
Um,
I'm sure you can rent the first DVD some even if you,
even if you buy it,
no,
don't buy it because then if you don't like it,
then you stuck with it.
Then I got to listen to,
you'd be a country but fucking,
uh,
go rented somewhere.
I'm telling you to great.
Show animals and winter break breaking bad.
Those are my three shows.
Other than that,
I just watched sports and,
uh,
and that is it.
All right.
This really tapered off in the end.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
You guys have a great week and,
uh,
keep everything coming and I'll keep doing the podcast.
I'll talk to you next week.
Please come out and see me.
Uh,
this Monday night,
this coming up Monday the 16th at the punchline yet San Francisco.
Well,
I'll come and see me in Saint Louis at the house of comedy in East St Louis.
All right.
I got a brand new.
Wow.
All right.
Make it snap.
You break out and
the street
[inaudible].